A seemingly throwaway line from Avengers:
Endgame got some comic fans' attention, as
it just may have teased the arrival of a classic
Marvel hero for phase 4 of the MCU.
Or, on the other hand...maybe it hasn't.
Such is the state of studies at Marvel Cinematic
University, better known as MCU, of course.
Be advised that major spoilers for Endgame
follow.
During his mission to secure more Pym Particles
at the SHIELD Base in 1970, Steve Rogers finds
himself in the office of director Peggy Carter.
He's taken aback by his proximity to his long-lost
flame and the picture of him lovingly displayed
on her desk, and let's be honest, so was the
audience.
It's a poignant, heartstring-tugging moment,
so it's pretty easy to miss what Peggy seems
to be saying as Rogers gazes at her through
the office window.
According to one intrepid Reddit poster who
claims to have seen the flick with a closed
captioning device, Carter says: "Braddock
hasn't checked in.
I'm not a meteorologist and it's not lightning."
Now, we haven't been able to directly confirm
that this is the dialogue she speaks.
And you probably know to take the average
Reddit post with a grain of salt in terms
of its overall reliability.
Additionally, Carter delivers the dialogue
while she's in another room, so the line itself
is pretty hard to hear without the aid of
a closed captioning device.
But if the post is accurate and Carter does
mention "Braddock," it could very well be
referring to a classic Marvel character who
has yet to show up in the MCU: Brian Braddock,
better known as the superpowered Captain Britain.
Making his first appearance in Captain Britain
#1 in 1976, Brian Braddock was a graduate
of London's Thames University, working as
a physicist on an experiment involving antimatter
particles under Dr. Hugo Travis.
When a villain descended on the facility to
steal the research, Braddock fled to get help,
but crashed his motorcycle and sustained what
would have been fatal injuries — and that's
when his story took a turn for the weird.
On the verge of death, Braddock was discovered
by none other than Merlin, the legendary wizard
of English folklore.
Sensing Braddock's heroic heart, Merlin gave
him a choice of two objects: the Sword of
Might, or the Amulet of Right.
Not believing himself to have the heart of
a warrior, Braddock chose the amulet — and
upon receiving it, he was transformed into
Captain Britain, with his own snazzy costume
and a bunch of superpowers like super-strength,
super-endurance, and flight, among others.
Captain Britain isn't the only prominent hero
named "Bradock" in Marvel Comics lore — the
other is his twin sister, Betsy Braddock,
who eventually became the superhero known
as Psylocke.
She showed up in 20th Century Fox's X-Men:
Apocalypse in 2016, played by Olivia Munn.
But Captain Britain does seem like a more
likely candidate for a future appearance in
the MCU for a few reasons.
For starters, Psylocke's own comic book origin
story is even more bonkers than the one we
just described for Captain Britain.
Not only that, but Psylocke's status as a
member of the X-Men cast of characters means
it's pretty unlikely she or any of the other
Marvel Mutants will show up in the MCU too
soon, since Disney's acquisition of 20th Century
Fox is still so fresh.
More importantly, however, is the fact that
Marvel Studios boss Kevin Feige has actually
admitted that he and his colleagues have discussed
bringing Captain Britain into the MCU.
In 2017, during the press tour for Spider-Man:
Homecoming, Feige was asked about the potential
status of a cinematic version of Captain Britain:
"We have discussed it, we have discussed it,
there are a lot of actors that come in and
ask about that, about that part.
So we'll have to see."
Could this be the first hint that Captain
Britain is coming?
Could there be yet another Captain being added
to the MCU?
Or is this all just one wild goose chase based
on a misheard line of dialogue?
When it comes to the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
all things are possible.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.